>> Greg: HER BOSS CONFUSED.
HER MOOD, AMUSED.
HER STAFF, ABUSED.
A NEW REPORT FROM POLITICO,
WHICH IS SPANISH FOR POLITICO,
DESCRIBES THE OFFICE OF VP
KAMALA HARRIS IS A DYSFUNCTIONAL
MESS.
HE SAW THAT ONE COMING.
IT'S LIKE A FRISBEE IN THE
DESERT.
THERE YOU GO.
I'M NOT FROM HIM.
YOU COULD SAY AND BORDERS ON
BUSE IF HE WAS SO AFRAID OF
PORTERS --
>> COUNT IT.
>> Greg: THE REPORT CITES 22
AND FORMER ASSOCIATES OF HARRIS
AND PRESIDENT BIDEN AND POINTS
THE FINGER AT HARRIS AS WELL AS
CHIEF OF STAFF.
ACCORDING TO POLITICO, FLORIDA
HAS BEEN OVERLY PROTECTIVE OF
HARRIS AND HAS BEEN AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THEY ARE
DRAGGED OUT AND STAFFERS GET
BLAMED FOR POOR RESULTS.
ONE SOURCE "THERE ARE SHORT
FUSES AND IT'S AN ABUSIVE
ENVIRONMENT.
PEOPLE OFTEN FEEL MISTREATED.
IT'S NOT A PLACE WHERE PEOPLE
FEEL SUPPORTED, BUT A PLACE
WHERE PEOPLE GET TREATED LIKE...
MEANWHILE, HARRIS, THE CHIEF
SPOKESPERSON, CALLED THE
ANONYMOUS SOURCES COWARDS FOR
INCOMPLETES TO THE MEDIA.
SHE DIDN'T CALL THEM RACIST, BUT
GIVE IT TIME.
OH, NOW SHE IS.
FRANKLY, I'M MORE CURIOUS WHAT
HER BOSS THINKS OF THIS.
>> LOOK, LOOK.
I UNDERSTAND THE PREDICAMENT OF
THE VICE PRESIDENT.
I'VE BEEN THERE, MAN.
I FEEL FOR YOU.
I WAS VICE PRESIDENT FROM 2,008
TO 1976, AND I CAN SUMMARIZE THE
WHOLE THING.
WITH ONE OF MY FAMOUS WHISPER
POEMS.
I DIDN'T DO A LOT.
BUT THAT WHICH I DID DO, I
FORGOT.
>> Greg: WELL SAID, JOE.
BUT I STILL FEEL FOR HARRIS.
EVERY STAFF HAS BAD STORIES
ABOUT THEIR BOSS, EVEN MINE.
>> TOLD ME ABOUT AN ODD TIME YOU
ENCOUNTERED WITH GREG.
>> ON TIME HE TOLD ME I DO WORK
ON SATURDAY, BUT THEN HE PICKED
ME UP IN HIS CAR AND TOOK ME TO
THIS CENTER FOR AT RISK YOUTH
AND WE READ TO THEM ALL DAY AND
HE HANDED ME THIS BAG OF GOLD
BARS AND TOLD ME TO GIVE THEM TO
EACH OF THEM PAID HE SAID HE GOT
THEM FROM WILLIAM TO VEIN.
THERE'S NEVER BEEN A BETTER TIME
TO BUY GOLD.
>> I'VE NEVER HAD A BAD
EXPERIENCE WITH GREG.
NO.
COULD -- YOU COULDN'T ASK FOR A
BETTER BOWSPRIT HE'S VERY FIRM.
>> EARLIER THIS WEEK HE WAS LATE
FOR WORK SO I WENT TO HIS HOUSE
TO CHECK ON HIM.
WHEN I WENT IN, THERE WAS 100
WOUNDED BABY BIRDS LAID OUT AND
HE WAS FEEDING THEM -- SPITTING
IT INTO THEIR MOUTH.
HE SAID WE ARE NOT GOING
ANYWHERE UNTIL ALL 100 BIRDS ARE
FED.
>> Greg: I FED EVERY ONE OF
THEM.
ALL RIGHT, MATT.
YOU HAD AN INTERESTING BOSS
AND -- LET ME CONTEND THAT WITH,
IF YOU ARE A BOSS YOU ARE ALWAYS
GOING TO HAVE ON DARLENE'S BAD
YOU.
WAS A HARD WORKING FOR
DONALD TRUMP?
>> A LITTLE BIT, BUT THE GOOD
NEWS FOR KAMALA HARRIS IS AT
LEAST SHE WASN'T ACCUSED OF
EATING HER SALAD WITH HER CALM.
I MEAN, THAT'S THE GOOD NEWS FOR
HER.
BUT THESE ANONYMOUS SOURCES --
THEY ARE COWARDS.
BUT AS TO SOME EXTENT THE
WHITE HOUSE AS A PRESSURE
COOKER.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE CAN'T HANDLE
IT AND YOU ARE ON A TIGHT ROPE
WITH NO NET.
YOU JUST HAVE TO DO THE JOB OR
NOT.
AND ONLY THE STRONG SURVIVE.
>> WASHINGTON, D.C., SMELLS
FEAR, THE MEDIA SMALL SPHERE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP -- CERTAINLY HE
KNEW IT.
KNOWING HE MAY NOT HAVE A CAREER
ARM MIGHT NOT END UP ON A SHOW
LIKE THIS...
LAUGHTER.
>> SAME THING.
I MEAN, THAT THREAD IS HANGING
FROM HIS JACKET.
>> GENTLEMAN!
>> Greg: KAT, THEY SAID 22
SOURCES WERE PART OF THIS
ARTICLE.
>> THANK GOD I DON'T.
NOT ONLY THAT, HE STARTED WITH
ALMOST AN ENTIRELY NEW STAFF.
A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE, I'M SURE
IT'S TOUGH, BUT THEY SHOULD JUST
BE LUCKY THAT SHE'S NOT PUTTING
IN THE OF THEM IN JAIL.
CAN YOU PUT PEOPLE IN JAIL
STILL?
>> NOT CURRENTLY, NO.
I CAN DEFEND THE WRONGLY
ACCUSED.
>> EXCELLENT.
WHY WASTE YOUR TIME WITH THAT?
YOU KNOW THEY PROBABLY DID
SOMETHING.
THE THING THAT BOTHERS ME ABOUT
THE STORY -- I MENTIONED IT
EARLIER, YOU MIGHT'VE HEARD
ABOUT IT.
I DON'T LIKE IT WHEN THEY USE --
I WILL CALL IT FULLY RHETORIC OR
INCENDIARY RHETORIC FROM MINOR
THINGS.
ITS MISTREATMENT, TOXICITY.
IS THAT THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT
LIVING IT ON 3-MILE ISLAND.
YOU KNOW THAT I MEAN, THEY ARE
WORKING AT THE NUCLEAR PLANT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Greg: WE KNEW WHAT HE WAS
SAYING.
IT'S FANTASTIC.
I JUST CAN'T BELIEVE WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE
VICE PRESIDENT'S OFFICE.
IT IS IN DISARRAY.
HOW HARD IS IT?
HERE'S WHAT YOU ARE GOING TO
WEAR TO THIS FUNERAL, GO TO THE
BORDER, WAKE UP AT NINE, GO TO
BED AT A REASONABLE HOUR.
IT'S SO EASY TO BE
VICE PRESIDENT.
ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM COULD START
IN AN HOUR AND HE BE KNOCKING IT
OUT OF THE PARK.
HOW WAS ANYTHING GOING WRONG?
AND OH, THERE'S LEAKS, THERE'S
LEAKS TO THE MEDIA.
THERE'S LOOSE LIPS AND KAMALA'S
ADMINISTRATION -- GO FIGURE.
LOOSE LIPS SINK SHIPS.
DO YOU HAVE TO BE NICE TO BE A
GOOD BOSS?
I MEAN, LOOK.
I'M A BOSS.
PEOPLE RESPECT ME.
THEY KNOW IF THEY CROSS ME, THEY
ARE DEAD.
DOESN'T THAT MAKE ME A GOOD
BOSS?
>> YOU NEED TO BE FAKE.
YOU NEED TO LEARN HOW TO
[BLEEP], WHICH WE WILL TALK
ABOUT LATER.
BUT AS FAR AS THIS IS CONCERNED,
I FOUND THIS TO BE AN
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE.
I LEARNED A LOT FROM HER
SPOKESPERSON WHO IS ALSO HER
SENIOR ADVISOR.
SO IT'S ONLY ONE PERSON WHO CAN
HANDLE BEING IN CHARGE OF HER.
SHE CAME OUT AND MADE A VALID
POINT THAT THEY ARE NOT MAKING
BUNNIES AND RAINBOWS, WHICH I
FOUND TO BE COMFORTING.
IF SHE WAS BREEDING RABBITS,
THEY WOULDN'T GIVE HER MUCH TIME
FOR LIGHT, I DON'T KNOW,
CONTROLLING THE BORDER.
BUT THEN AGAIN, THAT'S NOT GOING
SO WELL.
>> EITHER WAY IT IS A HAIRY
SITUATION.
I KNOW.
YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK?
I THINK DR. JILL IS BEHIND THIS
WHOLE THING.
SHE'S FEEDING ALL OF THE STUFF
OUT.
>> WE NEED TO GET TO THE ROOT
CAUSE OF THE DYSFUNCTION IN HER
OFFICE.
>> EXACTLY.
WHICH PROBABLY IS IN ECUADOR.
YOU COULD PROBABLY FIND THAT IN
GUATEMALA BEFORE YOU FIND THE
ACTUAL BORDER SOLUTION.
>> I THINK ALL THIS IS CAUSED BY
CLIMATE CHA